alo alo
anh alo
chứ không phải giống như hôm trước hôm
trước giờ quên là tắt ta thì ứng của hệ
thống Bởi vì tôi bảo đấy Tôi ghét mấy
cái tướng kiểu tôi thương ai a bật tắt
cái Unikey nó để tiếng
mấy hôm nay chỉ để các nhóm này bảo vệ
sinh trình chứ không phải là
học gì cả nên nó sẽ bị ám hơn nhà và
lãnh cả là ở
ở mấy cái buổi sau cũng buổi hơi nâng
cao một tí cũng kén chọn kén chọn người
học
trọng việc có bao nhiêu người xem một
người thì tôi vẫn sẽ dậy bởi vì À cái
này sẽ video của mình lưu lại thì về sau
ai cần thì xe ngọn chứ không quan trọng
việc là là cần xem trực tiếp Vì tôi thấy
cũng có khá nhiều bạn kiểu xem lại và
cho vẫn có người cận có người cần hiểu
thế không không xe trực tiếp tục thôi
tôi thấy thế
anh có ngựa bạn Bây giờ mới biết đến
nhóm của tôi trả bạn ai kênh của tôi
không ạ Bạn ấy mới bắt đầu buổi đầu tiên
HTML được ạ Đấy đấy này là cũng có người
này người kia mày đúng ạ
chào bạn
mình cũng bắt đầu dần nó nghỉ để đỡ phải
đội nhóm của lớp trưởng mà ông này nó
trưởng lớp phó rồi sẽ nhớ đấy Em bây giờ
ông lớp phó như mất tích rồi trao cho
ông làm lớp trưởng à
bày nhóm nào có trước khi trình bày
trước để tí còn thêm một vài nhóm nữa
tổng cộng hai hôm trước gặp lại cũng
chưa được 20 nhóm đâu Hình như là mấy
được 10 hơn 10 nhóm tí còn nhiều nhóm mà
chưa chưa chuẩn bị mà nhóm nào có trước
giữ trình bày trước rồi
thời tiết thay đổi
bây giờ việc là ở
áo kiểu dạng là
tinh thần đi xuống ý nghĩa là cứ mỗi lần
tinh thần tôi đi xuống thì y rằng nhà có
thể nó yếu theo
ở đây Thực ra là tôi là con người không
có sức đề kháng lắm
cũng giống như là tranh Thu Tâm sự tí
trong lúc mọi người chưa bán thì
em gà anh em dân công nghệ tôi quen ấy
thì ít người béo tốt đó
Chào tạm biệt anh em trong dư tim em ạ
từng nói là anh em trong như tin toàn
dưới 50 cân ý chứ khi lấy vợ rồi tăng
đột biến thôi
đấy thì à
Ừ anh em cũng kiểu ngồi cày ngày đêm
cũng chẳng đi sức khỏe gì cả
quyết điện tất cả tinh thần quyết định
vật chất này tinh thần quyết định sức
khỏe lại vật
giống giờ mày câu chuyện này là quan
người ta thường ấy kể là bệnh nhân ung
thư đúng không là quan đến thì chữa được
khỏi bệnh chứ gì đó
mà tôi từng đọc câu chuyện đấy tôi cũng
từng tin đấy
bởi Tôi nghĩ chỉ đơn giản là nếu mà con
người mà đi quan quá ấy người ta chắc
chắn là sẽ cũng không ăn uống sẽ không
sinh hoạt gì đó điều độ người ta sẽ trở
trong tâm trạng chán đời mà cũng sẽ yếu
thôi còn một khi mà
Việt kiều định lạc quan yêu đời Thì mình
sẽ ăn uống nghỉ nói cho ông
ông đã Lạc quan là ông sẽ sống lâu thì
ông sẽ tập thể dục con ông đã trả đâu
rồi Thì ông trả tập thể dục để làm cái
gì đúng không Chả thế
ừ ừ
từng nhóm trưởng bệnh à
à à
[âm nhạc]
ừ ừ
cái nhóm này phải trình bày thì hôm
trước đây
được đâu Hôm nay là mấy ông thầy mi có
vấn đề hay ở bên mít là có tiếng của
tiếng bị sao thì báo tôi nhá
để em cũng chưa vậy
Ừ Ok em em trưng bày chưa đi à
à à
anh
em nhỏ một chính em
chồng em làm quản lý điện biên thì đối
tượng nội dung thì có cắt ngang quản trị
viên với bây giờ có học viên giáo viên
với gia vụ
thì đi học viên thì tổ chức năng là sẽ
điểm thi của các kỳ bởi các vị đã học ở
năm học này
ạ bây giờ xem cũng chương trình của môn
học tiếng Hoa
chứ
không phải tất cả như thế nào Mỗi cái
mùi học nghỉ học được con thật là sẽ rất
tốt rồi đến thông tin của cái lớp đó
ở góc lớp aci tính năng lượng làm kiểu
riêng lớp vào tối
thứ tư là xem danh sách điểm các vua II
ở
Việt Nam là xem danh sách thông tin giáo
viên học phụ trách môn học
của mình giáo viên thì có xem cho sếp
con lớp với sinh viên đó từ hay là xe
đây xếp địa của sinh viên các lớp thứ ba
là xem thông tin tất cả các sinh viên ở
Ừ từ là xem thông tin xem danh sách các
môn nào chắc dạy à
nhàng lớp môn học giáo viên tiền bối
điệu
ờ ờ anh kéo kéo lên trên bên giáo viên
anh à
chỉ xem thôi giáo viên xem thôi không có
quyền mà thêm điểm đúng không
em vụ này
ê ê sang thực thể đi
ừ ừ
Ừ anh thấy ai đặt tên phố coi
khi phóng to tắt hai cái ở hai bên đi
không nói
[âm nhạc]
đó thì con to theo ảnh cũng được
anh chờ thì chẳng có
thì lấy
thằng Google này chị nó đọc được cái này
là ảnh
thực ra là do là thẻ Meta data của cái
thăm trang này nó tự tạo ra nữa
[âm nhạc]
ờ ờ
à à
Em Đi Rồi Anh thấy có học kì đâu nhỉ À
[âm nhạc]
Ô
kìa không không không bình tĩnh phim
phân tích Chức năng em ở gì nó người hợp
ý đâu
à À hiểu lên thêm vào Hay nhỉ
Ê mấy ông đừng lừa tôi Tôi nhớ mấy ông
đã gõ gì đấy
rõ ra là mày ông cậu lúc làm lúc làm
chẳng bám vào cái phân tích gì cả mấy
ông Cư nghĩ ra mà làm thôi
quay qua quay lại quay lại à
à à
a không à nhầm không vậy Kỳ đang nghe
nhỉ
đi tìm kiếm làm sao chiều ngày mai Kiều
Trinh anh đi cùng khóa chính kia Còn 100
thì có ba vì
em nghe nó cố định luôn à Kiểu tên mà nó
cứ thứ gì
hôn nghĩa giờ này ốp theo trường em đúng
không ạ
[âm nhạc]
hai kỳ này có ảnh hưởng đến những thằng
khác
vuông thì điểm nó có lương Đài Loan có
thế nào Lưu Diệu Kỳ chứ
cho điểm theo kìa điểm ngôn thế kiểu như
một kỹ lại tình đi học muộn ăn ngon này
rất kỳ sau mình học lại tình hình tại
lưu lại sao lại còn xem nhé thế đấy điểm
là một lần 2 rồi Đương ăn được gì đâu
chứ không phải là một ở thi gọi lần 2
thì lại thì rớt đi học thì cháu còn lại
tớ Thì đấy vẫn là lần 1 lần 2 rồi
chỉ cần 1 trượt lần hai cũng chưa Chị sẽ
thi lại quan tâm thì kỳ nào
à à hợp lại chứ
từ khóa học lại thì cái Điệp gửi đến xóa
đi rồi
không học học lại thì à
em à Anh hiểu ý em học lại thơm ra thì
như ở trường cũ của anh ấy nó sẽ ra điểm
lần ba lần bốn em ạ Nói chung là cứ tỉa
lần sau thôi Bởi vì về sau mình Nếu mình
muốn thống kê xem được sinh viên nào đủ
điều kiện tốt nghiệp thì mình chỉ cần
lấy điểm lần cuối của nó không quan tâm
lần thứ bao nhiêu quan tâm lần cuối của
nó mà quả trên 52 là được Em hiểu rồi
bởi vì sao nói thẳng quan Bun rồi nó
không có thi lại đúng không
ê ê
tác động mà có có liên kết hay tác động
với những thực thể nào không Nếu không
thì gần như nó cố định hỏi trong cốt
cũng được
anh bởi vì ở có bởi đi Ừ ở trường cũ của
anh thường gặp cũng có kỳ nhưng mà có kỳ
Có thể hiển thị trong cái chương trình
đào tạo cho trông nó đẹp thôi sẽ lưu
thoảng mã chỉ ở trong a số khi ở trong
học môn học đấy đấy nhớ là môn học sẽ
khi nào khi nào thế thôi cũng không quan
trọng việc
em không Có chẳng về sao điểm các thứ
thì ghi hai kiểu lâu hôi sau cái cái
phân phân phân lịch của giáo viên thì có
hàng Hoa Viên kiểu riêng thì này thì dạy
môn này thì thì sau dậy nữa cô khác đấy
à à
ở Phân lịch cái sân công nghệ thì anh
nghĩ là không cần lượng cũng không cần
phải lưu cả kỳ Em chỉ cần cứ dậy hết môn
là được mà nó có nghĩa là mã giáo viên
mãn lớp và mã môn thôi
a
và và ý Ý em là kỳ sau cũng sẽ dạy lớp
đấy và muốn lấy nữa màu hồng cực kì em
là kiểu như đi xem thế này thì kiểu giáo
viên dạy mua nào ấy
Anh hiểu thì sau này dậy môn nào thì ừ
thì đấy thì anh bảo rồi lưu mã kỳ vào
trong môn học là em biết rồi mà
anh đúng không em tự môn học em xảy ra
được là là kỳ này phải học những môn nào
ông bởi vì nó cố để ý anh là cố định đấy
em yêu thẳng cái mã gọi là gì một thì
hay nhỉ ba vào trong môn học ấy không
cần lại tạo thành của bạn nữa
em
vui Hạnh
ở đây không phải là kỳ một cái hay mà kỳ
trong năm rồi anh ạ
kiểu nó nó cố định mà Đúng không nhỉ
bình thường không đúng rồi nghĩa là theo
cố định theo 55 cẩu gọi là kỳ một xong
rồi thêm chữ kiểu năm nay và đấy nữa do
mà không
phải mất công nghiệp nhập cái kỳ vào
trong nó hơi hơi khó hiểu không
vì vậy
cho ở kỳ này tạm bỏ qua này tạm bỏ qua
đã tạm biệt rồi Đã xem xem các là học
thì chuyên ngành học phí trước ngày là
cái gì nhỉ
từ thế kỷ 12 Khi chính chính kỳ đấy à
à à
10 cái này khó hiểu của em ạ
Ừ cái này rồi không biết được em sẽ lưu
những cái gì trong ấy mỗi một hai ba bốn
thể nữa à
ở
mình thường ai lưu database ẩm chỉ là
thế sao mình dễ chỉnh sửa về sau mình
thích thì mình thêm một tí nữa cũng được
cái gì đó còn mùa khi nó cố định rồi
mình gửi sao không đổi thì nó bị thua
vào em ạ không còn lại lưu và này đâu
Mình cứ tạm cố định nó cứ tại 82 chính
kỳ gì đó cố định Hằng luôn cũng được
không sao
thông tin học viên thì có học kỳ thì kể
như hiện tại này thì cố định điều gì à
anh nói
cho este em em đã muốn lưu là sinh viên
ở đang ở kì mấy đúng không
để mà sửa sinh viên đấy lưu hai sinh
viên để học chậm đúng không ạ
i took a là cái đấy cũng dễ theo điểm
cũng được má điểm sinh viên đã nhập được
điểm thì sẽ sẽ biết được và sinh viên
đầy đã học đến cái mô nào ở kì nào
Ừ ok
anh vì em sẽ chẳng em có điểm à
ưu điểm rồi thì thì điểm của môn đấy rồi
sẽ trả lại đã học đến khi đấy rồi chẳng
hạn ngờ đâu nhiên kể nối Thế thì hơi hơi
không hợp lý lắm phải rõ ra là điểm
ưu điểm là em học xong xứ rồi thì mới
biết được kì học viên thì nó không hợp
lý lắm nhưng mà
Ờ Ờ
cái này nó lại liên quan đến bài toán
xem
về lớp học của em không cố định
chưa hiểu lắm
ở lớp trong cùng một lớp học sinh viên
có người khác thì nhau đúng không
Không có
ở nhà nghĩ thường để anh biết à đại học
trường quý thì sẽ có đăng kí tín chỉ học
theo tín chỉ thôi
Ai bảo không quan tâm mấy kiểu lắm nhỉ
ở trường em không ở thì chị như thế này
thì lên kế tiếp được hết
cố gặng giống trường cũ của anh thôi
chúng cũ Anh có Anh bảo rồi cũng có kỳ ở
trong môn ông kiểu kết thúc môn thì coi
như là
xong rồi thì không phải nợ môn đấy tiếp
đấy đấy nhưng mà vẫn học theo cả lớp cả
lớp thì vẫn học cùng nhau
và đến cuối năm cuối năm thì hoặc à đến
tầm mà cứ vài Hán thì sẽ tổ chức một
buổi thi lại hay gì đó cho những kẻ sinh
viên mà thiếu điểm của người môn mà kỳ
trước thiếu chẳng hạn thế đúng không Đấy
Và nếu mà xử nó thì lại không được thì
sẽ cho học lại nhưng học lại phải mở lớp
bổ túc sau
Anh chưa Còn lớp ở trên lớp thì vẫn học
giống nhau Lớp của em về Phong nghỉ
không hiểu thì lần hai trợ khác thì thì
sau học thì mấy nó kiếm lại thì
nó thêm vào lớp cháy hoàn đó thiếu đấy
thế mà không Không đi học cùng với lớp
cũ à
cố lên cố lên rồi đi học gì hay đây lên
kỳ tiếp là gì
ý nghĩa là không nghĩa là chưa kết thúc
chưa hoàn thành kì này thì không được
phép học thì sao đúng không
được học tiếp Nhưng mà có cái mông kiểu
nó kiểu liên kết với nhau hết kiểu không
ho được
Kiểu như hôm qua cái nắp này gì học
không không không cho muốn học tiếp vậy
à Nghĩa còn lại mới phải ngôn nó liên
kết với nhau hơn vài môn thì nó ép kiểu
thế đúng không ạ
ghét nhau của thế nó lại mình không biết
mình có nên lưu lại rồi đấy không cơ
ừ ừ
còn nữa cũng lằng nhằng ấy
ạ Bây giờ chúng ta là cái phân tích Chức
năng của em vừa rồi nó hơi bị chung
chung thành ra là khi thiết kế cái thực
thể này nó bị sai nó không Anh không
biết được là nó thiếu đầy đủ ở như thế
nào ngờ giờ để anh thử phân tích như anh
thừa Xuân Thịnh một vài toán nhá
ở đó là đầu tiên thì khi mà người dùng
vào trang web của em người dùng đầu tiên
ở đây lại là giáo vụ đấy người ta sẽ
thêm những người đi đầu tiên là sẽ nhập
dữ liệu vào những cái gì sau nhập dữ
liệu là những gì văn văn sau đó Đấy là
lúc mà khi mới có phần mềm của em còn
lúc mà đưa vào hoạt động thì người ta sẽ
bắt đầu thêm những cái gì và nghĩa là
đầu năm đầu năm học đầu năm của một khóa
học thì người ta sẽ thêm những cái gì để
sinh viên có thể hiểu đi học như bình
thường Vân tiếp theo là đến giữa năm học
thì phải nhập những cái gì và cuối năm
học thì giáo dục cần phải có những tính
năng gì đấy nếu mà em trả lời được những
câu hỏi đấy thì
phân tích ra được những tính năng mà
giáo vụ cần từ lúc mới dùng phần mềm này
đầu năm lại giữa năm cuối năm này gọi là
cuối năm ở đây chưa đủ chứ có phải lúc
tốt nghiệp này sáng ạ đấy Ừ thì em đã
giải quyết được trọn vẹn bài toán
Anh hiểu rồi Anh không
ở
đây thi đầu đầu anh đưa anh thử nói xem
có đúng trường em kiểu thấy em nhá Đầu
Năm Thì lúc đầu trước khi lúc dùng phần
mềm đấy thì giáo vụ sẽ vào Giả sử kỳ cố
định đi kiểu 153 Kỳ đúng không Không
Quan Tâm về dịch vụ là phải nhập tí nữa
rồi nhập kỳ Nghe nó buồn cười nào chẳng
thế đúng không tiếp sẽ nhập ngành học
này đúng không nhập ngành trước ơ
sau đó thì nhập môn này sau đó đi Môn
này có liên quan đến ngày không
em có có ngoan một môn thuộc bao nhiêu
ngày 21 môn chỉ có một ngày thôi
một môn sẽ làm triển có nhiều ngành cùng
chung một môn đúng không ạ Đấy Ok thế là
nghĩa là nhập độc lập đúng không Nghĩa
là đầu tiên đi nhập ngành này cái dụng
này lập trình ở ạ Sao nhập môn này giúp
web pp xong rồi và Vân đúng không Đấy
sau đó thì mình sẽ nối nguồn với ngày Ok
rồi Ok rồi nha tiếp à
hội nhập giáo lý ăn đúng không chưa nhập
giáo viên tạm thời là mình mình có cần
phải lưu lại là giáo viên có dậy được
những môn thì không
giản là cứ bỏ quá rồi đã Cứ cho là giáo
viên có thể mình tạm thấy giọng mình dặn
giáo vội vị giả vụ biết tạm vào viên là
dậy được những gì đi không cần phải nhập
phụ đấy vội đi Có chỗ làm nhau
Ờ Ờ
mình nhập vào viên xong rồi này sau đó
thì đến vào đầu năm này đầu năm thì sẽ
có nhập khóa này nhập lớp này nhập sinh
viên này đúng không Đúng chứ mà
sau khi mình nhập thế xong rồi thì cho
sinh viên học các thứ thôi đúng không
đến giữa năm thì bao nhập điểm nó sinh
viên nằm nhớ
[âm nhạc]
anh ạ
anh đi À cái này thờ ca là tùy em vừa
nãy em bảo làm thêm tính năng phân công
để biết được là giáo viên nó dậy lớp nào
thì cả thì anh nghĩ là cấu tạo Bỏ qua Bộ
này đã là thậm chí ở đây anh nghĩ không
cần giáo viên dạy bỏ con cả giáo viên đi
là mình làm chị hát tại vì em cả điều
này nhằm hãy kiểu giáo viên có cái gì
đấy thế Thế vào việc khác giáo viên gì
cơ vì cái còn lấy Điệp này hai triệu
giáo viên không được niệm gì về kiểu ý
chức năng đấy nó có chức năng gì Đúng
rồi em nên là xóa giáo viên được bài
toán quản lý điểm này thì ra không liên
quan là giáo viên đâu Gửi giáo phụ là
người nhập vào những vụ người quản lý mà
ở trường của anh thì giáo viên cứ dậy
thôi còn không hề biết được điểm sinh
viên luôn không và đương nhiên là giáo
viên Anh là người chấm chả viên vẫn là
người chấm ra vụ đó chấm được nhưng mà
nhưng mà có thể giáo viên chấm chéo
không có chuyện giáo viên dạy lớp của
mình rồi chấm lớp mình buồn cười đúng
không là viên sẽ chồng chéo và do vụ sẽ
là người nhược điểm Nếu là giáo viên của
mình cùng lắm là về sau có thể hỏi thôi
hỏi bằng mồm nhà bạn sẽ biết được sẽ mà
lớp mình có bao nhiêu thằng trượt bao
nhiêu lỗi ạ Chứ cũng không biết được là
điểm số cụ thể bọn nó như nào
Anh hiểu với anh
Ừ đấy thì thôi Các là cái đấy lại không
liên quan thì cái phần mềm này lắm nên
có thể tạm bỏ phải giáo viên được tạm bỏ
tính nam phân công đi đấy
thời tiếp theo là cái điểm Vừa nãy anh
nói điểm vừa nãy chỉ mình có bàn đó là
giả sử em muốn là thi lần 1 lượt thì
được thiền 2 nhân 2 trượt thì sẽ được
học lại bản chất là học lại thì mình
chẳng có lưu lại ở đây nhưng mà nhưng mà
nếu mà nó chị Họp lại nữa nha được thi
lần 1 lần 2 lại đúng không hay là như
thế nào nhỉ thưởng ở đây nếu mà Thì học
lại thuê giả sửa học lại phát nữa vẫn
truyền gì đó
anh em chẳng biết có gì đâu
có một sự thật lời ở trường anh thì nó
không bao giờ trường hợp hi hữu đấy
trường anh thì nó là trường kiểu vợ là
thi nó khá dễ dãi thoải mái nói thẳng là
trường anh thì cũng có hợp lại cũng có
ghi lại thật chứ Thì lần ba để cho xem
trước của kìa thấy lớp học lại nào ít
quá Thôi cho thi lại và Thi dễ gọi như
châm chước cho qua và học lại thì cần
nhờ rất là đỗ cũng chưa rồi có thấy
trường hợp học lại giận lần thứ hai bây
giờ nếu mà nếu mà em muốn làm cho nó mức
gọi là
sự chuyên nghiệp cho chuẩn là mình học
lại có thể bao nhiêu lần được thì bao
nhiêu lần được thì đương nhiên là mình
sẽ không có một cột cố định lần 1 lần 2
mà mình sẽ có cột là cột điểm và một cột
cột lần đúng không đấy
Anh hiểu hiểu gì anh không thì mình sẽ
có mã môn này mã sinh viên kiểu thi này
và lần và điểm đấy và lần này nó cứ tự
động Tam thôi đúng không có bao nhiêu
tầng bấy nhiêu sau đó về sau mình mình
thống kê thì mình sẽ ạ Lấy số lần cao
nhất của từng sinh viên để biết được
điểm điểm của nó đỗ ơi chưa đúng
Anh hiểu gì anh không
nhưng mà tiếp theo có thêm vài cái nhỏ
nữa vừa nãy em có bảo
Tức là cái này nó hơi bị ờ ờ
anh kiếm môn của em vừa nãy nói là nó có
liên quan đến Trì đúng không
à à
bộ môn có liên quan đến kỳ mà đúng không
ví dụ học kì 1 thì họ kp cơ bản xong rồi
kì 2 học VP nâng cao chẳng hạn đúng
không Chỉ tiêu Kỳ trên đời này
không không không không cần phải thêm
thực thể Kỳ và Lưu Hoàng Kỳ và sóng ngôn
nhưng ở đây lại còn những thắc mắc nữa
hết Nếu giả sử là môn ấy ở ngành lập
trình thì nó kỳ đầu tiên như ảnh của
nhưng mà là bên ngành bảo mật thì nó có
phải là thì thứ hai được không
Ừ rồi được đúng không Thì em phải lưu
lại cái thực cái cái mối quan hệ giữa
thằng ngành học và môn học vui Kìa em có
cái hàng trung gian là môn với ngày Đúng
không
ông không nối rồi Huế được hơi sai đấy
nhưng mà cái cái mua mấy cảnh đấy nó
phải thêm kỳ trong đấy nữa
Ừ có gì tối nay à
anh không bà không bảo tách hẳn một cái
cụ thể gì không ra không không không
không có tái cho sức khỏe về mình không
có chỉnh sửa gì ở đây cái kỳ không không
có thêm kỳ mới không oke 10 11 thì lấy
cả thì không có thể tách ra
ý thứ nhất à
ở môn học ấy cũng phải có kiểu có kiểu
thi nữa để lưu lại luôn à là
là kiểu kiểu thi của môn là lý thuyết
hay thực hành hay cả hai
áo kiểu sĩ này em thêm vào một trong này
luôn hả chứ chưa
Tại sao lại phải nối xanh đấy Tại vì em
có nên học gì à
phải không Không cần
môn môn web cơ bản chẳng hạn thì chỉ đi
thi lý thuyết môn web nâng cao ở khi cả
hai Được ạ thì thì phải tạo ra làm hai
môn nhá không phải mua nữa nhé
thi ở trong cái môn
a tiếp theo là lớp học của em xóa số
sinh viên đi vì rõ ra là mình lưu lại
cái mình đến được số sinh viên ở trong
lớp theo mã lớp là đúng
ta0 một lớp ấy có một sinh viên có thể
thuộc nhiều lắm à
ạ Vâng ạ
ở lớp của em nó hơi bị loạn đúng không
phải cố định lớp Nếu bạn Nếu thế thì
mình vẫn đến được không cần phải lưu lại
số sinh viên không về đâu Xóa xả cái đi
à
Ừ
nhưng mà cả lớp này là bản chất là lớp
Nếu thế thì theo anh hiểu lớp này theo
Môn đấy chứ đúng không
[âm nhạc]
Ừ anh hiểu thêm kỳ như bản chất là nó
vẫn theo muôn vì từ môn nó ra thời kỳ mà
[âm nhạc]
anh như thế phải lớp này có mã ngành và
mã môn Hiện Tại đấy là rất chuẩn đang
học môn nào hiện tại và lớp mạch thuộc
ngày nào để biết được là từ đấy thì sẽ
ra được
em ngoan thế thì lưu muỗi mang mã ngành
là mã môn mã môn Hiện tại thì rõ ra
anh em Em hiểu cái này không Bởi vì nha
Bây giờ giả sử ấy lưu mỗi mã ngành đúng
không Làm sao Làm sao anh biết được nó
đã học ở kì nào
cơm chứ Thì em sẽ phải có mã môn để em
nói sao cái thứ nhất cái thứ hai đó là
nếu mà anh chỉ lưu mỗi mã môn thôi thì
anh không hề biết được là lớp mày đang
học ngành nào bởi rõ ràng là một môn của
em có hiền thuốc nhiều ngày
hiểu đoạn hay không
ạ
Bây giờ trả nốt lại không kịp đâu xa Tí
xem lại nốt lại có dấu nhé
Hãy sở giáo viên đi Này xóa hai cái học
kì này đấy rồi các thứ tặng mới thế còn
học viên thì có mã ngành mã khóa
mở mã ngành thì có thể để lại này để về
sau mình nối sang lớp có dễ này khóa
Ừ ừ khóa để lại mã kỳ II
Lý Nhã Kỳ
cũng được nhưng anh Nghĩa lưu lại cũng
được bác kỳ hiện tại lưu lại cũng được
đều lại ở đây ở để cho vì sao mình đỡ
mất công nối trang điểm nhà Nếu thế cũng
mỗi lần em nhập điểm xong em lại phải ạ
cập nhật thằng học viên
Ừ nó hơi bị cái này ở liên quan này việc
em lưu Thừa Đã ta bây giờ để về sao em
đỡ mất công nói bạn áo kiểu em tự lưu
lại mã thì nếu có giờ sử học viên đấy đã
hoàn thành đủ toàn bộ môn trong khi đấy
rồi thì em sẽ thăm kỳ lên chẳnghạn đúng
không đấy
Em hiểu ý anh bạn nào
chứ làm sao mà giáo vụ vào nhập tay là
sinh viên này đang học kì mấy Có nghìn
sinh viên làm sao nhớ được đúng không
ở phần mềm mình phải làm vụ đấy đúng
không gần mình phải luôn kiểm tra xem là
sinh viên đấy à
Đang thiếu điểm môn nào đang học kỳ nào
đúng không
gì đấy đã học những môn nào rồi những
môn nào chưa học vào bờ Vân
Anh ấy giải quyết được bài toán đấy là
là con nhờ thành công thế phần mềm của
em anh thành công
Anh hiểu chứ
Ừ
Ok có những cây khác thì giường già tạm
xóa hết đi Ví dụ là
cấu hình nó gửi cái tạm hỏi mày tạm bỏ
hết chị ạ đơn giản chưa cả
Ừ Ok nghỉ họ có món tha món gì nữa
thì em sẽ lại có gì đấy hỏi sao mày Ok
em
à à
ừ ừ
Khi dòng tiếp theo nhỉ Anh ấy nhóm 24
game
à à
Em thích xe màn hình đi
tích quản lý cho thuê xe đạp công cộng
đối tượng sử dụng và quản trị viên nhân
viên và người dùng chức năng từng đối
tượng thì quản trị viên sẽ có chức năng
đăng nhập quản lý trang thông tin như pr
quảng cáo quản lý nhân viên quản lý
người dùng quản lý xe không quản lý các
trạm
ở các trạm để thuê xe nào quản lý lịch
sử gia vào của từng trạm quản lý giá phê
và quản lý loại phạt
Xem doanh thu chi phí mua và sửa xe
nhân viên sẽ có chức năng là đăng nhập
bảo dưỡng xe và cập nhật lịch sử sửa
chữa phí quản lý các xe trong trạm cụ
thể
cho người dùng sẽ có chức năng là đăng
ký đăng nhập tìm kiếm trạm kiểm tra
thông tin xe trong trạng quản lý ví Xem
thông tin lịch sử C lịch sử giao dịch
cho thuê xe đạp bằng quét mã QR thanh
toán thuê xe đạp và nạp tiền vào vía
chỉ cần Đây là mấy cũng đã chuẩn bị lấy
mình
ờ ờ
à à
ở đây anh bảo tạm bỏ qua mấy cái vụ ví
điểm anh sẽ không muốn dậy các bạn về
cái đấy vì cũng phải
em xin cấp quyền Làm nhà nữa không dễ
tại bộ qua vụ liên quan đến phí này
Thống kê vẫn thể thống kê các sự cố thứ
không còn yêu lại mày có lấy được
bảo dưỡng xe
chức năng đối tượng bảo dưỡng xe là gì
Em bảo dưỡng qua trang của em mà không
Tớ là sau khi bảo dưỡng là cập nhật vào
lịch sử sửa chữa phí
thì phải ghi rõ đúng không Ông bạn như
kiểu chồng em có tính năng ấy quản lý
các xe trong trạm cụ thể Cứ phải là gì
em nhỉ rất là một nhân viên sẽ làm việc
ở mỗi chặng cụ thể
đúng rồi ở Nga mà quản lý các xe chị tất
cả như thế nào à Chỗ này em chơi game
chứ quản lý các xe trong trạm cụ thể là
sẽ kiểu cuối ngày sẽ xem các
Khi
[âm nhạc]
bữa ngày sẽ Xem các xe đấy có cần đi sửa
chữa bảo dưỡng
em đi đâu liên quan gì nữa trang web
mình đâu ạ
ở khu thể trang web mình thì phải làm gì
cụ thể trang web của em là
tôi sẽ xe đạp ở cùng cá nói hoàng nhân
viên nó sẽ làm gì trên trang web của em
nhận diện
sự cập nhật lịch sử sửa chữa kín
không gian lịch sử sửa chữa và phí và ạ
Chứ còn gì nữa
hết à
chú ý thế
thì tại sao thằng còn chả kia hả
để cập nhật thông tin xe
của ông ngồi chơi à
nhiều hơn tớ
anh
không không ai còn thấy cả à
anh nhân viên không phải là hành diệt
xem là thuê không à
à hay là cái này tự động
em để cái này tự động ạ
thuê lại phạt
chẳng làm gì đấy chỉ vào xem lịch sử do
đúng không ạ Không ra với lại nhật thông
tin về
đi
xe đạp định giá thuê
khi mở quy định về đăng nhập một lần
thôi vợ
ạ sau đó thì cứ ngồi xem người ra đến
thu xe của cứ Mượn xe của ông sao ông cứ
sờ vào thường xuyên theo dõi giá hơn gì
đấy vợ
à Còn thằng nhân viên thì chủ yếu ở sửa
chữa đúng không ạ
Ừ cái mô hình này thì nghe vậy hay đấy
nhưng mà thực tế áp dụng thì có những
cái mà các bạn làm lại khó làm điển hình
ở cái viên tự động này xong rồi nó liên
quan đến tiền nhiều hơn chứ còn là
à Còn phần mềm trang web anh thấy đấy à
không có mấy
Ừ em đi có mấy đâu
có những cái gì đáng làm ở đấy
mà không không có cái ví da thì chả có
tính năng gì có thể làm lâu rồi làm gì
có đương nhiên nó có thêm cái vụ là biết
được xe nào đang được thuê không nhưng
nó ra người dùng cũng có lên mạng để mà
kiểm tra điều này ông có có
đi
tìm kiếm trạm kia đúng không Vợ à mỗi
thế thôi à nít quá
của anh hả hay là đề tài em tự nghĩ ra
vậy đề tài em tự nghĩ à
Ừ cái tay ra đi tay cũng được như ý anh
là nó bị hơi bị ít quá à
viên về cơ bản hãy nêu lên chẳng làm gì
học quản trị viên thì vẫn chỉ lên để mà
xem thống kê liên tục ở nhiệt toàn bộ
mọi thứ một lần
Ừ cái này thì nó lại có những cái bài
toán phức tạp và thứ nhất là liên quan
gì ví đây quét mã QR được ôm người thư
viện về có xong mặt tôi rồi thôi
tìm kiếm này và cập nhật theo thời gian
thực nơi cái cập nhật theo thời gian
thực thì nó lại cũng áp dụng lôi một cái
công nghệ nào đó về trước còn bài toán
thực tế về nghiệp vụ thì anh thấy không
có mấy
à à
ở đó không xa em mãi muốn cái này cũng
được nhưng mà ở đây ạ
anh như thế thì phải làm như mày đi đó
là em phải có quản trị viên nên phải có
thêm cái duyệt
nhưng bắt buộc phải có cái gì ở duyệt ở
đây đi chứ nhân viên chỉ lên mình ngồi
ngắm như thế này thì phần mềm người ta
không cần phải ra cũng dùng được
Ừ đúng chứ
người ta ghi vào trong sổ Excel cũng
được Tại sao người đăng nhập vào phần
mềm của em
đấy thì
người đó sẽ có thể duyệt là nhân viên đề
xuất sửa cái xe này
ạ sau đó thì quản trị viên duyệt cái đấy
Đấy cũng là một cái rồi
Lê
Hoàng lợn chín như anh bảo ấy đó không
cho tự động cho nhân viên cũng là người
duyệt cho thuê
Ừ
vợ dịch cho thuê xe
Anh ở giống như kiểu thuê xe online II ạ
Bây giờ không phải thuê xe đạp nữa
Chuyển qua Xuân quá thuê xe máy Online
Đi đấy đấy sẽ là
sẽ là người dùng nên chọn xe Sau đó thì
xem ổn hay không thì thuê có thể đặt
trước gì đó đúng không đấy cho nhân viên
sẽ duyệt cái ruột cái đấy đấy
đã sôi làm hợp đồng các hữu thứ để mình
lưu lại à xong rồi quản trị viên trẽn
mới xem cái đấy Và nếu mà em thích thì
em làm thêm tỉnh Nam là như anh bảo đấy
nhân viên muốn sửa chữa cái gì thì sẽ
tạo khế yêu cầu gửi lên cấp trên được
cấp trên duyệt cái đấy thì mình mới có
mình mới có chip mình mà có kinh phí để
mà sửa chữa chứ không hướng lên rửa
hướng lên sửa rồi thường lên đòi tiền
đưa cho ông
ừ đấy thế Thế thì nó sẽ là một bài toán
khó đầy đủ hơn
anh tặng sửa cái này đã tạm hôm nay trà
sữa chữa vội tạm sửa lại cái đề tài này
đã Bởi vì nếu mà không thì anh thấy đề
tài này nó ôm chị ôm các thư viện với
công nghệ về chứ không có cái tính năng
nghiệp vụ thì mấy cái bàn hai anh yêu
cầu các bạn làm bài toán nhiệm vụ nó khó
một tí để mà đi làm thì mình quen em chứ
nếu mà em ạ ôm cái công nghệ về nghe
phải hay đấy nhưng mà ở công ty em không
dùng công nghệ lấy cũng như ở công ty em
làm những bài toán khác em không biết
làm em em hiểu cho anh không ra cái này
thì cái đồ này phí ra anh đúng không anh
ấy anh không có tâm các bạn dù công nghệ
gì nha anh quan tâm được các bạn hiểu
được và dán như vụ phân tích được xong
rồi nó nó giải quyết được một cái vấn đề
gì đó
à Còn cái này thì em hoàn toàn thể làm
past two check là làm cái phần mềm riêng
của em sau được chứ giờ vợ Ok hai bạn
thống nhất thế nhỉ Bạn kia phản đối
không
tạm tạm viết là ý tưởng thì em ạ
nói mấy ông chưa Nhưng hồi mà tôi làm đồ
án hay Tôi nghĩ rằng nhiều ý tưởng lắm
rồi thầy rồi gà phát toàn bộ ý tưởng tôi
đi để mà tôi về làm phần mềm nghe chưa
Một phần là do nhà trường thiếu người
làm phần mềm ấy thứ hai ở đâu là mấy cái
phần mềm của tôi chỉ áp dụng một đống
công nghệ chứ cũng không có phải dẫn
nhiệm vụ gì cả thầy thấy à kìa Nó bị phí
phí cái thời gian làm thì cứ cho là phím
chất xám cái gì đó đi thầy muốn tôi Chứ
thực sự làm cái bài toán nghiệp vụ gì đó
to tát
Dù gì tôi cũng sẽ phải khắt khe mấy ông
như thế có thể mấy ông nghĩa như ý tưởng
ăn nhưng tôi sẽ gặp nó đi thôi bởi vì
mấy cái ý tưởng Đấy là mình tưởng
cho nó hợp cho pejic giống như cái trang
web chia sẻ nhạc của tôi không ạ dõi chả
có cái gì màu mẻ đó chị ạ ý tưởng làm
cái gì đó thôi nó không có phải đón Vụ
gì đây
anh đi họp eject để mấy ông làm riêng
sao còn bây giờ tôi cần thì tôi cần bài
toán phức tạp một tí để tôi còn chữa do
người ông tôi hướng em ấy ông không phải
là để mỗi đi làm nghề này đâu nha nếu mà
đi làm mỗi ngành này theo kiểu Junio
festa thì ông xong cái đoạn cơ bản để
ông thì đi làm rồi còn cái đồ ăn hai này
nó đồ ăn sâu mà tôi hướng đến mấy ông
nhà học xong rồi đấy Không cần phải đi
ra công ty faster ông thể tự tin ông bảo
ông Yukio mức lương thì bảy tám triệu
luôn để đỡ mất công các công ty Linh Đào
tạo loại nữa nghĩa là ông phải hiểu được
làm được một cái bài toán nhiệm vụ hiểu
từ đầu đến cuối một bài toán ông làm
được
cho
nên nó sẽ hơi bị khác em cái gì nhưng mà
thả khắt khe như này có người chỉ còn
hơn ông lên công ty xong rồi công ty vất
ông một đống tài liệu rồi chẳng ai chỉ
ông cả đúng rồi ông rồi thấy khóc
Ừ ông ấy đi thực tập ở đây rồi nhá hết
đàn ông đều biết được à Nên công ty có
phải ai cũng sẵn thả chỉ tay mình nó
đúng không nó sẽ vứt ông cái đống tài
liệu và lượng khí hậu không đi làm thì
lại chẳng quan tâm nồng say biệt danh
rất nhiều ông lên công ty 2 tháng thử
thực tập nhưng mà thứ hai tháng lên ngồi
chơi cũng chả ý kiến gì à
em nói chán lắm không
ông tí em à Muốn thực sự là tôi đang
hướng đến mấy ông lên Junior đó là thật
thì Sino mà Mấy ông muốn lương nghìn đô
thì bắt buộc phải khắt khe thôi
Dạ
em 21 được nghỉ à
lệ giống nhóm em lòng về đề tài chính là
quản lý lớp bổ túc đã thận sẽ dòng Nó
chính là admin
admin Super admin giảng viên và sinh
viên
thì admin có những tính năng Đó chính là
quản lý tài khoản hệ thống quản lý báo
cáo thống kê quản lý giờ học ngày học
chương trình học và quản lý thông tin
sinh viên người nào về diễn viên là quản
lý lớp quản lý thông tin sinh viên người
học sinh viên chỉ nhà thông báo ơi
à À đây là xin lỗi cực thế
mình đấy mang tính quay qua quay lại mà
à à ăn kẹo kẹo kéo lên trên Ánh Trăng
Ê thằng em là làm cái gì nhỉ à
I max bổ túc hình lớp của thu hoạch khu
có khẩu tên đề tài trên của gọi
tắm hả Ừ
vụ tai nạn
Nghe giảng viên quản lý thông tin người
học ở như thế nào anh không hiểu lắm
thiếu xe con tinh là sẽ thông tin các
thức ăn
những video không ai trà sữa tinh tinh
là bia thì dậy rồi nó bổ túc thì giáo
viên được thuê về để dậy lớp thôi
Hà
Tĩnh Cái này hôm trước anh chữa cho một
nhóm một nhóm rồi Em đang mắc lại giống
hệt nhau đấy đấy đầu tiên thì lớp bổ túc
của em nó nó có cho sinh viên đăng ký
không Hay là mình tự đăng ký cho sinh
viên hay như nào thì mình thấy đáng kể
cho sinh viên tự đăng ký sinh viên nghĩa
là kiểu sinh viên học ở trên lớp rồi
không ổn thì mình sẽ tạo lớp mới cho nó
thì nó mua thuốc gọi là được à
ở chỗ ép đi học à Lớp Học thêm à
Nhanh giống à
Ừ
rồi thì giáo viên nó cũng không có chỉnh
sửa gì cả giáo viên sẽ điểm danh hiện
nay cái lớp này thôi
Nếu mà lớp học thêm như em bảo thì chắc
chắn phải cần điểm danh luôn
anh đúng không em sinh viên có đi học
hay không giống nhiều nó học lại chứ nói
thẳng giống kiểu nó hợp lại à
bây giờ học ngày học
Nghĩa lên lớp lên lịch đúng không nên
thời khóa biểu cho sau giờ học này họ
Ừ Ok sáng sáng thực thể đi
ừ ừ
khi sex
đó là ta có
còn nói Làm thế nào để sinh viên em đi
học mà chết là giáo vụ sẽ phải vào cái
danh sách lớp để mà chọn một vào danh
sách sinh viên đấy ạ ạ sau đó chọn một
loạt sinh viên nào
anh
nói chung là không ổn gì đó nằm cách
thần kỳ ở đó cảm thấy không ổn gì gì đó
sau đó tạo ra một danh sách
Ừ để mà tạo ra một lớp mới hay là có sẵn
danh sách để rồi chỉ tạo nỡ thôi
Ừ anh ấy là có sẵn danh sách rồi
Ừ Ừ cứ cho là có một sẵn anh sang Excel
rồi đúng không Chỉ lại sau đó thì mình
tạo lớp thôi đúng không
như thế thì cần gì nhàng thả môn nhỉ Có
mô thôi chứ làm gì Cần nhà nghỉ đâu cuộc
sống thì thường là lớp bổ túc như này
cũng là lớp bổ túc theo môn cơ mà
nữ diễn viên gì đó để xem gì quản lý
phải lớp buổi tối thôi Kiểu thúc thêm
thôi Anh nghĩ tạm bỏ nhà nghỉ
khi họ sẽ môn mà
tự nhiên là môn của em có nhà nhưng mà ý
là không cần phải nối đấy á cái một môn
của em thuộc nhiều ngày hả Hay ngay ạ
mộc màu chỉ cùng một lần thôi đấy thế
lốp thì sẽ còn mạnh phone để ám chỉ là
lớp đấy sẽ cố định luôn học môn này và
kết thúc trong vòng 22 mưa à Cứ cho là
20 buổi ạ Đấy giống y hệt lớp bổ túc
bình thường thôi em đăng kí học đi sẽ là
em đăng kí học chính chỉ em mình rung
không sẽ là học 20 buổi học Ielts em ạ
Đấy chỉ học hay học có gì mua nó khác
đấy
anh cứ nhớ sẽ có nhà nhưng mà môn của mã
này này ở lớp có mã môn này Đấy lớp
không cần của mã này sẽ được
từ khóa kia là code là khó à được nghỉ
cách tạo mở khóa đi em ạ cứ cho lớp này
học thì những cái lớp như này ấy nó học
môn như này rồi không quan tâm đến việc
là sinh viên đấy thuộc khóa nào nữa bởi
vì có thể sinh viên học lại cùng nhau
thoải mái mà trên đều không thì nói Ít á
đỡ mà ít người lắm Nếu mà em chưa rồi
đấy điều đó
anh xóa khóa Đây này
ra em không cần phải lưu đầy đủ thông
tin của sinh viên trong trường này nữa
bởi vì bản chất là toàn bộ thông tin
sinh viên và lưu lại ở trong cái phần
mềm sinh viên khác rồi còn đây Mình chỉ
quan tâm danh sách sinh viên khó trong
nước này thôi Em chỉ cần lưu ý thôi là
không cần thực thể sinh viên đông lạnh
được cùng lắm là vì xin không cần đăng
nhập vào xem đi alo siêu nhân đăng nhập
vào xem thời khóa biểu cũng được nhỉ
vui lòng gửi thị mê luôn
anh không ý anh à vào đăng nhập để xem
thời khóa biểu của bản thân cũng là một
ngày hai ờ cứ tạm thời Thế thì cũng sẽ
chỉ cần có email và mật khẩu thôi
Anh pha xóa mấy cái kia cùng lắm là tên
này
ảnh đại diện à
không có ảnh đại diện thường mà mới phân
biệt chung cái ảnh đấy
Anh ấy tiếp theo
cô giáo viên vào xem mày xem lịch học
nghịch dại của mình này
ở lớp thì cũng sẽ có
à hóa bỏ khóa đi đúng không Chỉ có môn
này kia con đi ở số lượng ạ ạ ạ
e500 mình đến theo rồi đấy mình sẽ không
cần lưu đấy Xóa đi này ờ
các thứ trong tuần à Whitney là thứ
trong tuần đúng không ạ
buổi ở đâu Mình sẽ nói theo một quán
ngồi này nhưng mà không phải là thực thể
Ừ ông thời khóa biểu đó thì thể em cách
a nó được thể bản chất là một lớp nó sẽ
có nhiều thứ ba biểu
em đứng nhất
ở lớp chị một thời khóa biểu rồi à
Ý nghĩa học nhiều nhà ấy học nhiều Buổi
để có điểm danh mà Bây giờ có nói có
điểm danh mà đúng không ạ
anh em làm thêm điểm danh đấy không thì
nó chả giải quyết được cái gì cả chỉ xem
được phân công xong rồi sinh viên vào
xem được mỗi cái mình đã được ạ
Mình thì cái biểu của bản thân thế là
kết thúc của cái phần mềm này nó bị nhạt
nhẽo em ạ
Ừ em anh hiểu cho em không nó xuống nó
không giải quyết lấy gì cả chỉ vào xem
thôi ạ Sau giao diện chỉ vào xem thôi
thế thì cần gì dùng phần mềm của em có
đầy phần mềm kiểu tạo thời khóa biểu
cũng có mà
Ừ
nếu mà phần mềm về cái kiểu để mà học
thêm như em bảo ấy thì nó rất cần điểm
danh
môn thì mình sẽ lưu lại
số số buổi cần phải học lớp thì sẽ lưu
lại mã môn sau đó có gì nó sẽ nối sang
với thằng điểm danh với thực thể điểm
danh ấy trước thời điểm danh nó sẽ bao
gồm mã lớp
mã giáo viên thế thôi
ở Bà Điểm nhanh chi tiết thì nó sẽ là có
điểm danh với sinh viên và tình trạng đi
học sinh viên đấy đúng không Không cần
chấm điểm thì đây cả
em có nghỉ trong lớp thì có thể lưu lại
mã người tạo lớp đấy à mã do vụ tại nước
ấy cũng được
Ê bà cái đúng rồi cái điểm danh thiệu sẽ
lưu lại là là thứ học thứ nào nữa mà giờ
nào nữa
Anh hiểu thì hiểu gì anh không hiểu và
cái cái cái điểm danh gọi điểm danh như
thời gian nó thời khóa biểu diễn mà phải
biết phạm ra trước trước khi mà dậy
Anh Hiểu
ý nghĩa là ví dụ là à
bình thường là cứ cho là cuối cuối tuần
đi Cuối Tuần Giáo vụ sẽ là người vào tạo
thời khóa biểu cho giáo giáo viên và lớp
này trong tuần sau là học như thế nào
đấy còn về sau nếu mà muốn tiện hơn cho
người dùng thì mình Hãy ấn nút copy nút
sao chép tất cả mình sao chép tuần trước
học đúng giờ này buổi này thì tuần này
cũng sẽ học đúng tuần này buổi này à Giờ
này Bữa nay đấy kìa thế thế được
Anh Hiểu chứ Hiểu
Ừ thế thôi phần mềm anh Nghĩa cũng chỉ
đúc kết thế sau đó thì về sau cái bài
toán
đấy Cái đầu vào đúng không còn đầu ra sẽ
là gì đầu ra sẽ là về sau Kết luận được
là giáo viên sinh viên nào đã học đủ số
buổi để tốt nghiệp lớp này và sinh viên
nào còn thiếu buổi gì đó đúng không
Ừ thế thôi cái đầu ra là như thế
số nhập
Ừ
ok còn thắc mắc gì không nhỉ ừ ừ
em huyền có gì thắc mắc thì nhắn anh sau
nha Ừ
ở đây nhóm tiếp theo nhỉ à
đến nhớ 14
Ừ ok
à à
Cô Linh ơi Linh mở màn dùm tôi với
đây là tài liệu của em rồi
thì
sai của em sẽ có 3 đối tượng người dùng
đó là Anime và giáo viên và học sinh
Ừ thì an ninh thì nó sẽ là quản lý giáo
viên học sinh và bài tập thì nó sẽ
anh tìm được những cái ho đối tượng đó
anh còn học sinh thì
có những
có những chức năng như là tiền lớp học
Em có hiểu
đi tìm lớp học tham gia lớp học
à à
khoác lớp học rồi xem như sách lớp học
đã tham gia
có thêm vi phạm là được cảm xúc phạm
Ừ nó tương tự như là Google classroom
vậy ta
à Còn giáo viên thì sẽ tạo được lớp sữa
lớp 6 Plus xem như sách học sinh ở trong
lớp đó
rồi mà học sinh số học sinh rồi theo
mình tập sự biên tập sách thật
Ừ
thì có bản website của em là có những
chức năng này
chú Bình Đấy Minh Tĩnh Mình chưa Cho đổi
vậy Đây là trong phép quản lý bài tập đã
ở Dạ
cái này ở cho sinh viên à
a cho giờ đúng không cho đại học đúng
không Giờ đúng rồi
Ừ anh chưa hình dung được này lắm chưa
thấy vợ luôn thấy có cái vụ tự nhiên
tham gia lớp với toán thật
nó tự tưởng là Google Chrome nhanh thì
tham gia lớp học là học sinh sẽ tìm lớp
học qua cái mã của lớp qua các bạn lớp
học không không không Cái này anh biết
Anh hiểu Nhưng mà cái này nó bị làm thế
sinh viên nó vào tập nhanh lắm mình nên
quản lý được cái này giáo vụ sẽ là người
tạo lớp và thêm sinh viên và lớp
Âm Nhạc
Cô Giáo viên sẽ không có quyền làm sữa
lớp gì cả giáo viên chỉ được cụ thể được
phân công vào lớp nào xong rồi Dao bài
tập cho lớp 7 thôi sẽ là người thêm đâu
nha Sửa 6 bài tập thì thoải mái đúng
không đều sau đó thì thêm bài tập với tạ
deride các thứ thứ để mà học sinh sẽ vào
vào tài khoản của mình sẽ thấy cái lớp
mà mình đã được Kiểu được không được mời
vào các thứ thứ vào đấy xem cần phải làm
những bài tập gì đấy Sau đó thì nộp bài
tập trên xanh đấy ngon xong thì sẽ vào
đấy xem bài tập sinh viên đã nộp để chấm
chất thức rằng chẳng cần chấm thường là
thường là cứ cho là mình cứ làm đơn giản
bỏ qua vụ điểm số đi Mình chỉ cần duyệt
Thôi việc là sinh sinh viên này đã thực
sự nộp bài tập về chưa vậy Có nhớ thằng
nộp kiểu file trắng tinh ở là bị em ạ
Thấy ở đây thì mình sẽ là người vào
duyệt
anh đúng không sau đó thì giáo vụ sẽ có
kết quả đầu cuối là giáo vụ vào xem danh
sách của một lớp sẽ biết được là có bao
nhiêu sinh viên thực sự đã nộp bài tập
rồi bao nhiêu sinh viên chưa nộp hai gì
gió vân vân đấy ok chưa
đúng giờ như thế
toàn bộ Tình Anh của ông phân tích loạn
rồi rồi rồi sang bên thực thể
nên chuyển qua bên kia luôn
đây loại sơ đồ thực thể của website
à à
cho anh nhìn có rõ không
Ừ Ok Ok Tạm tạm không cần nhìn hoặc
admin không xem mấy thằng kia ra được à
anh ở đây có đầu tiên như anh vừa bảo ấy
thì đầu tiên là mình sẽ có
Nghe danh sách sinh viên trước
Chị linh tinh Nếu mà danh sách sinh viên
theo lớp kia thì cố định một sinh viên
thuộc một lớp mà
cô
sinh viên kia là thuộc một lớp rồi ạ ạ
Anh ở sinh viên có thể thuộc nhiều lót
anh
một nmn đúng không sinh viên thuộc à
Nhiều lớp đúng không ạ
ạ Bây giờ là ngày đúng không ạ
à à
số ngày nghỉ phải có một cơ thể nữa thể
nữa thực thể nhàng đúng không đấy à
a giá rẽ phải có một thể ngày nữa sao
nói đến nữa nói đến sinh viên nói đến
lớp nói đến giáo viên
thì tại sao phải nói đến lớp rồi vì ạ
biết được bởi vì
từ lúc đầu tại vào lớp Sau đó bắt đầu
ngồi sinh viên nó lấy mà
thứ hai là khi mà tạo lớp và lớp lập
trình ở ạ thì ngồi những cái bạn ạ
em không cho bình tĩnh đã
cái này theo môn mà nó tại sao ở lớp nhỉ
mở cửa mồm kem mây chờ ra là chỉ để lưu
những thông tin bên ngoài hơn nếu mà
không ai đây vậy Gì anh à cái lớp này
này nó lớp theo môn mà ở đó xa mô ạ
thì đúng hơn
nhé Bây giờ ông mới nhận ra được đấy ạ ạ
ạ ạ
nhưng mà bạn sẽ là lớp để trẻ học một
môn thôi đúng không chị thì phải có một
môn không Nó là vẫn là class thì vẫn
đúng rồi nhưng mà vẫn phải thì uống và
thực thể có thể Môn
vì vậy thường thể ngày nữa ông đoạn Thấy
rồi
ê ê
ở thời tiếp theo là ở
anh hoài ở chùa đoạn đấy sai nhá Đấy
phải trở lại nha Tiếp theo là
bài tập này tạm bỏ qua comment chú thích
đi à
cái tát hả submit
thì tại sao phải tạo Làm file đấy tạo
lắm cơ thể nhà anh chơi rồi lắm
a fast nào
còn Smith là mình nộp vào
Em hát bài tập Ok
gratis này Bài tập vì em lên cho đính
kèm file em phải có thêm 1 file nữa
Ừ thế em định cho người dùng gõ sai mỗi
mỗi mô tả rồi à Không Thường những giáo
viên có sẵn file bài tập rồi nên có
những cái khay minh họa với không lấy
nữa cái tiếp theo sắp Mít
a xít anh cũng phải có thêm file nữa là
em có cái Smith Tiếp theo là cái tát ý
xây ở bên trái cái đấy nó lại thực thể
thấy tinh ở Xóa đi Xóa sát
thì cả em em nghĩa Em sắp ít đường nhiều
file nhớ pha Giá
ở trường lại ở trường tôi cho sắp Một
file thôi Nếu muốn ngừa file nén vào
trong quay lén Xiaomi một cái
trường em cho shop nhiều quá
hỗ trợ trên Google earth II
Em đừng có nói Google Glass Ở đây có
class chấm phần mềm em làm gì
[âm nhạc]
anh alo ra nghe
Ừ ok sắp nhiều file đúng không ạ
là nó thì nó Nếu thế thì lại sai nó là
một nó vàng
có một nó sắp ít chứ
ông nói gì mua một đi không lên đây à
Thấy một vài Đúng không Đúng không ạ Nếu
mà ông là một mục tiêu chuyển một file
thôi
anh ạ ở đây là một file
Em hãy comment kia thì à
số comment Không phải của men I
ờ ờ
Mà mà Giáo viên sẽ chấm vào cái sắt Mít
là một sát mí thì có nhiều file và giáo
viên sẽ duyệt từng Người Sắt 1
a cho một giáo viên có thể diệt nhiều
sắp đi Á và một sắt mỹ thì đương nhiên
được Diệp mà giáo viên đúng không lẽ nói
chung và một lần nộp bài tập của em có
thể nộp phiếu file đúng không ạ sau đó
giáo viên chỉ cần chấm một lần nộp đấy
là Đạt hay không đạt hiểu đơn giản vậy
thôi cả bạn đấy
em
sửa sửa sửa Dạo này rồi hôm sau hôm sau
hoặc ngày mai
chụp lại nộp anh nha Còn phân tích thì
nó bị loạn hết rồi dễ thương quá
ca nhạc Ok
ừ ừ
khi con nhóm nào đâu
nhóm này
Lê Minh nhóm mà lại tôi mất tích đâu hết
rồi à OK OK
nhóm 12 Ok
đã trình bày về nó gọi em là quản lý
lương và quản lý và điểm danh và Lương
của nhân viên Trung Quốc đi
viên thì đùa chứ thằng Tưởng tượng thì
quản trị viên còn đây pho sắt và đi
trong bộ phận bị xuống nghiệp nhân viên
điểm danh của anh lương nhân viên thì
bao gồm là đăng nhập sắt cá nhân chiến
tranh xâm lược bằng tay cũng là máu
và trị viên
Anh là thằng đấy sử dụng này không biết
là có xem cái kiểu mà là nhân viên chỗ
có cao
sự quản lý của một khó khăn thì có thể
trưởng bộ phận
Ừ cũng đúng ra là quản trị viên ở đây nó
bị hơi say rồi không có người ra Mở quả
trứng kiến thì mình ở trong không có
thông tin sẽ hay là cái đối tượng sẽ còn
lương đến xanh đấy Ý anh là
thực ra là một công ty cụ thể thì nó sẽ
là kế toán và kế toán trưởng và có
trưởng bộ phận nữa và quản trị viên ở
đây thì da ẩm thực tế nói chuyện là quản
trị phần mềm thôi nó không có những cái
khuôn bia à khi con quản lý vị trí công
việc hay các thứ của em rồi bảo nhưng nó
chờ đợi Triệu bộ phận
a How ghi là nếu bộ phận nó thay đổi em
xong ta bây giờ thay đổi cái này cậu có
đi xuống việc nó sẽ bị bỏ đi và thay
bằng không vị trí người khác
ở vị trí công việc khác là như thế nào
nhỉ ý là ví dụ ban đầu thì có vị trí là
như vậy Banking thì sẽ bảo người ta bỏ
đi không đi chị ấy mà thay đổi Tình Nhạt
Phai
Em à anh ấy hiểu Anh hiểu như ý anh à
quản lý nhân viên Thực ra là quản trị
viên không có tình không được em làm
được đấy đúng không phải bên nhân sự
đúng không ngờ cho Nếu là theo một công
ty rõ ra cái phần mềm này nó sẽ có khá
nhiều người dùng chứ không phải là có
mỗi hai đối tượng đúng không ạ Ừ thực ra
mình có làm đơn giản phải toán các thủ
đã còn bài toán về sau rộng hơn em Bố
làm đấy hình như anh vừa bảo thì thứ
nhất là có trưởng bộ phận này mà quản lý
nhân viên của mình thế cao nhất giữa hai
là kế toán sẽ người xét duyệt Nhưng cái
toán trưởng mới là người duyệt Xem thực
sự Cái cái đấy nó sắp về chưa hiểu về nó
nhưng mà anh điện em ạ Đấy còn điểm danh
thì được cao là trưởng bộ phận sẽ là
người xem đại cái điểm danh của từng
nhân viên mình
chứ không phải là kế toán đúng không
Đấy trưởng bộ phận sẽ là người gửi lại
cái điểm ra anh ấy để làm chó cho kế
toán cập nhật luôn thôi đấy thì không
Nói chung là thông qua rất nhiều nước cứ
liên quan hết tiền rồi nên nó rất nhiều
bước rồi Còn nếu như em đang làm mày nói
chỉ có hai bước thôi một thằng Điệp ra
anh còn một tháng hết vào diệt lừa thằng
kia đúng không để công ty dở hơi ít hơi
ít nhân viên 21 kiêm nhiều việc
mà
chị thì chậm con mua vé quá
Ừ ok nhưng thôi không sao nó giải quyết
được bài toán được rồi sang thể đi
mà chị thì
đồng hồ mỏ ạ nhau đây Đang làm gì là cái
Ta bảo người yêu giờ thì nào đi làm sao
bám tay luôn à cả quản trị viên và nhân
viên là một thì thay một lễ hội
vào nhau Chúng là phát ra à
Ừ Ok anh hiểu anh nghỉ
về sau đó chỉ là cái thằng đó là
[âm nhạc]
Phòng Ban và vị trí công việc thì xong
ấy mộc nhân viên và từ cái đấy thì
phòng ban là
file và học sinh có gì ạ Và cứ đi là ok
ok
có
gì ạ
bí mật ong với 1 em điện và Paris chị
rồi chuyện là cái ở vị trí phòng 35
chính là gì ở mỗi một viên thì tướng mới
một cái bình tĩnh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh
bình tĩnh đợi tí anh phải anh anh Nghĩa
đoạn này em có thể làm cách này
Tại sao thì cho đỡ phức tạp về sau là
thằng nào được phép diệt à
e hèm thể tách riêng cái thằng ngu dơ dơ
bàn thắng ở xã hội liên hồi vào thì nó
cũng nên tự do cho Hồng
Ừ ừ nếu em lại thì kiểm tra quyền của
level mỗi khi mà làm cái gì đó
xe ga cục lửa
là cái cái kiểu như vậy không sao cả
Nhưng ý anh là liên quan việc là thằng
nhân viên này nó sẽ có thực ra có phải
lương hiện tại nữa kế toán thì không có
điều đấy hai em tự diệt lương với chính
mình
mày à Em chưa nghe gì nó bảo là như bảo
này thì cả em chưa Nó là cái như bên là
sẽ còn gì ra cái đó thì em sẽ học chắc
em đi không phải là ban đầu là chỉ có 22
đối tượng mà sẽ được cái nội dung ấy thì
em không rõ được như thế nào em Bây giờ
tao phải là cái giỏ này mà đau đầu em
định đổi à còn sinh viên thì còn như là
phải có hệ thống các kiểu mà nhân viên
phòng ban chưa Ý
i keep abreast là gì nhỉ là cái phần cái
này
để tính
này chính ra xe máy 5 tháng
cho nhân vào
page nó là các phòng ban này Chức vụ này
tỷ tỷ lệ à luôn lưu lại những thằng này
là thằng đấy
anh
em dùng từ ngày lương và nhân vào theo
mức lương một ngày mà như sao
Ừ ừ Hử ví dụ cho anh thường ngờ Bây giờ
nhiều vàng bình thường là 27 ngày hạnh
như 24 này thì em lấy mức lương cũng cảm
thấy là mất lương sau này và nhân 24 lấy
ra dù làm gì chào là một ngày là có 2k
buổi sáng buổi chiều thì làm được đấy
chỉ là một lựa một tính là một ngày làm
việc và nhấn nút đưa một ngày việc thì
ra luôn cả đã
Ừ Anh hiểu ý em nhưng mà cái này thì ta
chỉ cần lưu lại cột lương chứ cần gì vậy
cô tỷ giá trị Bởi vì nếu mời Nếu ạ Nếu
mà Sao lại đổi vị trí mà không gọi lại
em có lưu lại là sau đó Kiểu như luôn mà
salary thì em xem lưu là chó cái lịch
sướng anh lịch sinh
a cab for cutie ID và Royal thì như là
xong công việc trong một cái gì thì em
vẫn có xem lịch sử là của nó được là cún
đây
em à Anh hiểu mẹ không cố định theo từng
nhân viên mà theo từng rô đúng không kêu
em xinh là hai cái tao vẫn ở quán cơm
chiên và cá rô ok ok
ở hiện tại em dùng Tablet Thì ra anh Hải
không đúng lắm
cái này Suri mới đúng chứ nhỉ
chọn sau đây là chút nữa tháng và nổi
tiếng trong ngày thì dùng từ khác
ở
sa mạc
à À ông trả lương theo ngày ở ông không
tính lương theo tháng à Làm gì có những
này là nghỉ Kiểu như không suy nghĩ là
mình bận thì nó giữ dáng
thôi
ở
công ty anh em nghĩ là kiểu như thế này
thế nào thì cũng là chia nhưng mà sẽ
tiện hơn ạ Bởi vì nếu mà họ làm thêm
taka kiểu nữa mà có thể cho tăng thêm
thì sẽ thấy trách nhiệm thì bị Trưởng
Lương trong ngày vì không taka sẽ chúng
ta Ok mới gắn card âm thanh card em có
gì nữa anh anh hiểu em anh giải quyết
bài toán hiện tốt ok
a tiếp Cheri
Cheri Lady
[âm nhạc]
thì tại sao phải lưu lại nhiều cột Kia
nhỉ à nếu nếu lấy ra đi học đi nghe rõ
nè là nó thay đổi cái việc chạm gì em
tăng từ vị trí này thì được là tăng lên
vị trí cao hơn là sẽ ăn hạt thì nó sẽ bị
thay đổi cái nước cũng là cái lịch sử nó
sẽ đổ hết những hồi làm đồ ăn mồi giá ạ
Ừ anh hiểu rồi đấy nhưng mà chị em muốn
lưu lại đi này thì cái phần startup nó
sẽ triệu
Nếu trường hợp thay đổi cả tên của bộ
phận của bọn này cái bộ này nó bỏ hứa
bạn đi thì em sẽ bóng con không được
phép xóa rồi đấy không có phép thay đổi
đấy nó không đi với đầu tròn cho nó họp
công ty kiểu cảnh như đá nhỏ sao hả chị
chỉ công ty đấy là bộ thông tin thay đổi
phần công ty thay đổi nhưng mà thế thì
để đấy là thay đổi cái mát thôi còn
không không được phép Xóa Họ nhiều trẻ
nó ra khóa ngoại mà
tiếng bình tĩnh bình tĩnh nghe anh nói
lại cái Sorry đúng không Sorry là để tụi
kế lương cho trong 1 cho một tháng nó
nha không rồi Ờ
thì em chỉ cần Lưu lại uid lưu loại sáng
em mất thì tháng rồi này không cần phát
không cần phải lưu lại nó đang ở phòng
ba này Chức vụ nào Tại sao bởi vì a thì
lúc này không cần quan tâm cái Chúc cụ
cũ của nó là gì và chỉ quan tâm và tháng
ấy là trả bao nhiêu rồi đấy thì em sẽ có
pate nhà em lưu lại là cái cái hồi đấy
là nó cũng được trả bao tiền một ngày và
một ngày à và tháng ấy làm bao nhiêu
ngày đấy nhé mình sẽ cụ user đi rồi
và măng và yêu hai cục đấy sẽ là ba cuộc
đời nó sẽ khỏi chính để phân biệt được
là tháng ngày đã trả lương Thằng đấy
chưa Đấy tiếp theo page thì ở
Hi hi cái vừa rồi em có nói làm anh nghĩ
đến thực ra nó lại có phải toàn hơi bị
nó hơi bị ở thường ở các công ty nó cũng
không tính theo kiểu để lắm đó sao đó
giả sử em làm nửa tháng rồi tự nhiên
được thăng chức thì ở lương của em tháng
sau nó bất rồi cậu chứ không phải khá
hay được cộng luôn đúng không ạ
Ừ đấy thì ra nó không phải hiểu gì cả
Nói thu và thả cái cột bảng bảng salad
này thì sẽ có sẽ chỉ có xóa Xác cụt
posse ngồi và rodi nó không cần em chưa
gặp này tiếp theo cái check tất cả cái
điểm danh không nhỉ mở
ưu điểm danh nhà mình sẽ có biết là
người đi này
morris sáng trưa chiều đã sẩm tối
thế
Gì đang đánh này Em tính gọi làm rồi
nhau một cái buổi sáng thì chào là một
chú lần được 5 ngày làm việc không ạ
em mình nó ngày làm việc buổi chiều nó
đang gặp Nếu như thằng k tăng cao tăng
thêm phần cao tối nữa đang hiểu Kệ xuống
cao hơn hơn
ừ ừ
thì nó phải Còn chữ y là chiếc áo ấy nhỉ
a a a
ra thật ra cái số giờ trên Nhưng cái cao
thì mình biết là buổi rồi nhưng mà thấy
kỳ mình có thể
Ừ cứ cho là k1 k2 K3 nhé Vợ bảo cả ba
đối tác đường ạ thì họ sẽ có là đế là
Jose đi này và K3 cái đấy sẽ khoa chính
và và từng ca rồi nó sẽ có chuyện chứ
tao đấy bà em sẽ làm như thế này đấy anh
thử nói qua cho đó là kiểu em nếu mà
thích nhân viên vào vào buổi sáng vào
phần mềm buổi sáng cái đấy được Ca phần
mềm mình tự check được đang là buổi nào
tiểu học Đa ca nào đấy Sau đó thì vào
buổi sáng Ấn Ấn Hiền anh cái sẽ hiểu
check in vào ấm điểm danh phát nữa dễ
hiểu cho cao đấy và
nói cho nhân viên thì đỡ giả là bấm bấm
như thế thôi phần mềm với cái tên mình
điểm danh hiệu chấm công bằng vân tay đã
thực hiện nó chỉ quan tâm Điều lấy thôi
quan tâm mình bấm vào lúc nào thôi Hiểu
đấy thì
ở buổi sáng bấm 1 cái buổi trưa đi ăn
bấm cái nữa lúc nào ra buổi chiều lại và
bấm xong rồi Lúc đi về bấm với nó nữa
đấy thì nếu mà giả sử mà quên bấm thì
đấy thiệp nhân viên chẳng quan tâm hiểu
chứ
Đấy thì mình có lẽ luôn chỉ kiểm tra kín
Cho tao xin trích ra và số ca thôi khi
nó sẽ là có cột biết là ozid và Coca và
vào một cộng đồng chí kia là buồn của
chiếc ao sau đó đi từ đó mình sẽ giúp E
việc thế thôi không chẳng cần phải lưu
lại mấy cô kia thì cả vì sao mình em
mình dùng Hà mình tính ra
ok chưa Em đang chuẩn như vậy nó là
sorry Bởi vì nếu mà sẽ họp là em vỏ tới
anh chọn vị trí công việc là nó không
còn tồn tại thông tin cho em xin nói cái
nó sẽ không tao được không thì nó không
tồn tại như là không có nghe thấy chỉ có
một lưu lại vì xong thì công việc đó là
bao nhiêu Mà tại sao nó được đơn như thế
số lò xo 120 hiểu là Xem hành trình mình
là lên phát triển hướng nào và chính ở
nhân lên xem nữa
vì nó không lưu lại trong bảng lương rồi
ạ
em còn nếu mà em muốn lưu lại sao Mà
lương thì thật là em như lại không phải
là khai xây tid Hero đi mà em lưu lại
fashion êm và your name phạm để đỡ phải
cho để về sau nếu mà nên đơn giản
vừa để đợi roi vừa để nếu vì sau
cái lô hay các City Thay đổi cái tên
chức vụ thì cái thằng cũ nó không bị
thay đổi nếu ngày một rừng muốn xem thể
thao nữ LG em đi hướng là những thay đổi
tên gì đó thì em thì cho là thêm mới mà
chị xem thằng Út nữa
Chị ơi nhưng mà ý anh ạ thuế Nếu mà em
lưu lại cái này bản chất cái này lịch sử
lịch sử để không được phép thay đổi hiểu
ra anh không Nó giống kiểu hóa đơn chi
tiết mà vừa nãy nói và lịch sử sẽ không
được Alo gì cả Mình sẽ lưu lại toàn bộ
những cái đi rồi đấy ozid thôi nha vẫn
nên có rồi nhưng mà toàn bộ những cái
khác có thể thay đổi thì mình sẽ lưu lại
nêm vừa để đỡ mất công roi để đề phòng
vì sao thay đổi thì cái cũ mà vẫn còn
nguyên chả biết rồi đấy
ý
là mỗi thế rồi thì là thứ thiếu ấy user
ID ghi ở trong bảng
Serie nó có hai Rơi đi một người người
người tạo cái đơn đấy một chút dây đi là
người được được Kiểu được duyệt lương
đấy
đấy thì rõ anh bảo phải tách lan hay vừa
vào ngày nọ không Ông quả tạo
thành đô thị
trước khi khám thì không sao bởi vì mấy
cái này mới có nghĩa là mấy ông cũng ít
tiếp cận và cái này nhưng mà đây đây đây
Đấy thêm lý do mà mày không phải tiếp
xúc với mấy cái bài toán viên phụ này để
hiểu
ở đâu nhỉ À
Còn nhóm biết nhau nhỉ à
vậy đúng không nhóm 27 mà có ý tưởng và
làm sơ đồ rồi thì cứ trình bày thôi nhà
em thì chắc từ 7 ạ
ờ ờ
điểm danh này lòng thấy màn hình của em
rồi
Ừ ok rồi em ạ
âm
thanh đáng chú ý
giờ thì nhóm em sẽ đó làm về đề tài phân
tích phần này Văn thì trong đó sẽ có gồm
các đối tượng sử dụng là còn có một shit
vào mặt min đây là người quản trị hệ
thống
ở nhà giáo vụ giáo viên và học viên
chức năng chính cho từng nhóm đối tượng
trước toàn bộ pin thì sẽ có chức năng
Đăng nhập đăng xuất cái tài khoản của
chính mình cung cấp tài khoản cho giáo
phụ và giáo viên
cũng như là sẽ quản lý trên hệ thống của
mình
ba đối với cháu vụ thì sẽ có chức năng
cơ bản là đăng nhập đăng xuất quản lý
giáo viên tạo tạo Đăng ký lớp học
Lịch học cũng như khóa biểu đăng ký ca
làm việc quyết định sẽ định chỉ Hoàng là
Nội môn cái sinh viên rồi có mà vi phạm
cái A
Ừ cái cái làm mức độ chuyên cần
đối với giáo viên thì sẽ có đăng nhập
đăng xuất tinh anh cho sinh viên đăng ký
ca làm
thế này thì thôi
theo dõi cái lịch dạy học của chính mình
cũng như là sẽ gửi cái báo cáo chính anh
gửi email trong từng thấy giống liên
quan đối với học viên thì sẽ có chức
năng Đăng nhập đăng xuất Hệ thống mô và
hệ thống của phần mềm theo dõi được cái
lịch học Xem chi tiết cũng như là giọng
được cái thông báo điểm nhân của giáo
viên
Bạn theo dõi các môn học Lịch Sử môn học
của mình Ok anh thủy
phân tích của vợ nhóm này khá chi tiết
sau nhiều nhóm đấy
ừ ok ừ nhưng mà ở đây đợi gì
ờ ờ
em à Em làm là cao học với em rồi
Ừ cái cái cái xúc à Tại vì nhắm trúng em
là sẽ quyết định có hai cái sáng hay
chiều
Ừ giỏi quá ha mà không phải full thảm
nhà có thể là một giáo viên nó sẽ quyết
định là sẽ dậy chị sáng mà là gì một tí
do nào đó họ sẽ có thể lên vậy khuôn này
thì nó sẽ có báo sàng là vậy buổi sáng
thì buổi chiều gọi là Diệu cả ngày
Ừ
anh ấy anh hiểu rồi em nhưng mà cái này
thì
cũng linh hoạt nhỉ nghĩa làm chuyển biến
theo tháng này thì mình có thể vào cập
nhật là dậy rồi Cả ngày tháng sau một mí
thể và tắt đúng không Giờ đúng rồi nó sẽ
giúp cho cái giác uyên linh hoạt hơn
giáo viên dấu hiệu hoạt hơn trong cái
việc mà muốn
hiểu đúng không Dạ Đúng rồi Dạo này khó
hiểu cho nó sẽ không nhưng ra vụ đăng ký
ra làm hả Ừ vợ có thể là mình có thể là
em không muốn là trong cái hệ thống này
sẽ gồm có nhiều dấu bụng giao vụ theo em
như hiểu là nó sẽ gần như là giám thị
nhưng mà giáo vụ đăng ký ca làm thì ai
người xem cho vụ cạp của giáo Vũ nhà thì
sẽ tạo mặt pin sẽ quản lý được cái cái
cái cái cái làm của nhóm bụng tại vì sẽ
có cái hắn còn không bình tĩnh system
admin ở đây là người làm hệ thống đã nếu
mà như em bây giờ Nếu vậy thì em sẽ tìm
lại cái cây đăng ký làm tại vì em đang
muốn là sẽ bật pin sẽ giống như là một
người những hiệu chữ vậy còn là một số
người đó mà sẽ cắt cao nhất
thì cứ cứ soi là giáo vụ trưởng cái gì
đó như bản rất đấy vẫn là giáo vụ thôi
nghĩa giáo vụ đăng ký sao k làm ở giáo
phụ Nhìn thôi là mình sẽ có một cái rau
muống trưởng để quản lý thì nó cũng khác
Ừ cũng được Nếu đấy phải theo rô Nã
Ừ rồi Nhưng mà nếu mà nếu mà trong cái
phạm vi của mình là thì em có thể là em
sẽ cho nhóm vụ đăng ký cố định cái cái
lịch ca làm luôn
Ok Ok xong thôi thể xem
là đối với tập thể
sẽ quản lý thì nó bụng
là một giáo bộ sẽ quản lý được nhiều
giáo viên cũng như là có khả năng tạo
được nhiều cái lịch học
có thời khóa biểu
cô giáo phụ sẽ có cái đăng ký tờ này
nhưng mà Thì chả nhớ là như vậy thì em
sẽ bỏ cái mô hình này I
sẽ đến với cái đối tượng là nó viên thì
giáo viên là sẽ gồm có là giáo viên tên
có được cái người và nhau bụng quản lý
mình cho điện thoại email Cái tình trạng
đi làm là hôm đó họ có đi làm không mà
họ đăng ký trên mã k nào ở đây là mối
quan tâm cũng không thôi không bình tĩnh
mình sẽ đi làm là là hôm đó là mình có
đi làm không quá anh không không không
không lưu được lấy ở trong bài được
đương nhiên là có thể không là đáng để
đấy cũng được đấy cũng được là xem vì
sao là mấy con là cái dâu Bình nó có đi
làm đúng mà thoát ra lòng mình mở rộng
đến hệ thống là cái
viên nào đóng nghỉ thì cái tình trạng đi
làm nhà có thể có thể lưu lại nhà mình
sẽ giống như là đây nó sẽ giống như là
cái cột đấy mình chiếc xe bò xe mà cái
cái cái đâu mà Đúng rồi Đúng rồi nghĩa
là lúc nào cũng cho giáo viên đi nghỉ
Không không đúng là nó xóa giáo viên đấy
nó viên đấy nhỉ chứ được chứ chắc cũng
phải là tình trạng đi làm hôm nay rồi
nhá thấy sai
nghỉ
thì đúng lúc đó tình trạng đủ em ạ tinh
thần tại em không bú và này nó như là
PIN này có phải là vì một cái lý do đó
có thể là ý
nghĩ tài sản thì sau đó cũng ngồi đây
chúng ta sẽ được tạm thời mình cho cái
dấu biết nói được nhỉ Đúng rồi bởi vì
mình không xả được giáo viên mà vì nó
nối khóa ngoại những bản pháp gì ạ Ừ ok
tiếp theo lịch nhóm vì nó sẽ quản lý
được giáo viên một giáo viên sẽ có nhiều
lốp và lót với lại Áo viên sáng có nguy
hại gì nhiều với nhau để anh lên đây mà
phóng to lên thoại gì vậy ạ
anh ở đây là em có cái mối quan hệ vợ
nhiều
tiết giữa giáo viên mà lớp à
lốp xỉ số nốt cái vị trí nốt trồng cây
cung viên trường là cái tình trạng tôm
không không kho Không phần mềm mình
không cần xử lý mà toàn đấy thứ nhất là
sĩ số có thể đếm được mà vị trí bỏ qua
lại xóa xóa hai cái
tình trạng lớp ăn tình trạng Lớp của em
nó là gì nhỉ nhà em đeo mũ là cái lớp
này khi mà mình đã đủ với số lượng học
viên chị gió cũng mới đăng ký có nghĩa
là cái cái bài toán ở đây là phải có đủ
số lượng học viên thì mình mới có cái
nốt cái này là trường học bình thường mà
phải luôn mở lớp chứ nhỉ Nếu mà chết
Chết từng họp tại vì em cũng nâng cao
lên chữ như là dù là chồng vừa là trung
tâm đấy à
vì nó có thể là nó sẽ có cái này ấy mà
không anh Nghĩa tình trạng lớn ở đây
mình làm đơn giản thôi tính trạng lớp
đấy có tình trạng đây sẽ chỉ là lớp với
tốt nghiệp này chưa Thế thôi nhỉ Nhưng
mà thôi thôi cứ cứ dễ nhìn cứ tạo Bỏ qua
Bộ đấy đã tiếp theo tiếp xanh xanh mấy
cái khác mà
có nhiều nói mày thì sẽ còn có nhiều môn
một môn thì sẽ có thể có chụp cái nhàng
với nhau nên là em có một cái nói nhiều
nhiều ở đây không phải ngồi lại mã ngay
ở trong lớp chứ
anh em Hãy nối lớp sang Môn hả Thế rồi
rồi
anh
alo mãi
nhàng lưu lại mã quá đấy nhá
ca nhạc không lời
thiếu rồi
ý nghĩa là một khóa có nhiều ngày đúng
không như một ngày chỉ thua 1 khóa cơ ạ
khóa sau thì không anh đấy à
Ờ Ờ vậy là cái cái này cũng phải làm
phải muốn hệ nhiều nhiều chứ Đúng không
Đúng rồi em không thích sai chỗ này giờ
tôi nói thì thì cả lớp nó sẽ lưu lại mã
này mà mã khóa để biết được là sinh viên
của cái lớp nào sẽ phải học những môn
nào và khóa nào đúng không được
mình lĩnh cái này Tí xem xem sau Ok
sinh viên bạn ơi mình sẽ có ạ
ở đâu đó sẽ có nhiều sinh viên
lịch học thời khóa biểu nó sẽ có mã lịch
học mã giáo viên
a
mã môn mã lớp
khi mở
kt38 vụ là người thêm cái biểu này đúng
không
còn Giáo viên là sẽ người là sẽ được
phân công để dạy cái cái cái lịch đó hai
rồi mà vẫn K
a mã k thời gian ca giờ đúng rồi má ca
là em có cái mũ là thì sáng tới chiều
thì nó sẽ có cái cụ thể thời gian cái
này giống như một cao ốc xanh Sài Gòn nó
không quan trọng
ra thì nó cố định Mà em vì vậy nhưng mà
nó cố định thì mình chỉ có hai buổi đúng
không
anh cứ để nó cố định em ạ
anh
em sẽ không không tạo sự thể này mã cả
kia thì mình cứ hiểu một là sáng hay là
chiều chắc là thế là mình mình chỉ có
hai cái mà không còn tin cho cái ca đó
mà cái anh bảo vừa nãy nhóm luôn nãy đó
là em chỉ tạo thực thể và lưu lại trong
đây khi mà em có sửa xóa về sau có thay
đổi Còn nếu ở vì sao em vẫn cố định thế
thì em lưu lại chả làm gì cả à à à Dạ
đúng rồi ạ
a
chú Bình đấy nhá Mình định nhá Nó bị sai
kìa Cái điểm danh không phải thực thể
nếu trong trường hợp này
danh này thì nó sẽ có mối quan hệ điều
nhiều mới là cái lịch học đây ví dụ như
là trong
ngay hiểu em chưa mà cái lịch học phải
lưu này nhá luôn á
à Dạ đúng rồi nãy là em muốn luôn cái ca
Để em before tới cái cái cái cái ngày
cái gì nó không thấy
k00k thể điều khiển tạo ra nhiều lắm tôi
không được à
nữa
cái lịch học này nó sẽ là nó là điểm
danh đấy Và cái cái nối giữa điểm danh
với sinh viên là điểm anh chi tiếp nó sẽ
không có thằng là thực thể điểm danh đâu
ở
mối quan hệ giữa hai thằng đúng không
Thì nó sẽ có mã điểm danh này và mã sinh
viên và tình trạng đi học của sinh viên
đấy
vì vậy là nó nằm hết tất cả trong cái
lịch đấy đúng không À đúng rồi địa lịch
học của em bản chất bản chất là ở đây nó
có hai trường hợp xảy ra đó là bột là là
giáo viên cứ được phân công nhà phần còn
bộ bằng phần mềm nhưng mà không hề biết
được ạ là mình không lưu lại ở trên phần
mềm là mình đã bọn mình phải dạy vào ca
nào mình phải dậy và thú nào mà gần như
là kiểu phân công bằng mồm ấy gửi thế
gia vụ sẽ bảo là anh đến vào 2246 chẳng
hạn anh dậy và ca buổi sáng giống như ở
trường cũ của anh ấy ấy sau đó thì giáo
viên sẽ vào
khi vào lớp vào những buổi đấy và tạo
cái điểm danh vào hôm đấy để điểm danh
còn cái phần mềm mỗi em hiện tại thì nó
sẽ làm là nó phải tạo khiến thời khóa
biểu trước sau đó người Giáo viên sẽ là
người vào để mà Cập nhật cái điểm danh
cho sinh viên thôi Còn cái điểm của anh
thì đã được tạo trước cái lịch học đã
được tạo trước rồi giờ đúng rồi đúng
không Giờ đúng thì hay đóng cái lịch học
này nó sẽ được tạo kiểu theo tuần em ạ
phần sau những buổi nào để tạo chẳng lại
thế bây giờ phòng hoặc là chìa khóa này
là cái gì đấy
Ừ ok tại mới thế nhỉ ờ ờ
anh cũng phải sửa lại vài cái nối lại
nha chị thì mình sẽ bỏ luôn cái cái cái
nhau miền có thể đăng ký trong này theo
ca hơn
cũng được vẫn đường mà không được thì
tuần sau em cứ nghĩ là nó sẽ không có
linh hoạt tao cái việc mà giáo viên mới
cập nhật là cái tra
con gà Nếu mà theo thời khóa cửa lại
phải cố định rồi Nếu mà nếu mà để cái
này thì nó chỉ giống như là cái lịch học
chúng ta sẽ cố định cái ca cái nó đúng
rồi đúng rồi linh hoạt ví dụ như hôm nay
là buổi sáng có thể thấy buổi chiều ra
thì cái thường mà em hay Nhưng mà
thường là một giáo viên sẽ được dậy được
phân công ấy là Quân công một cách sẽ
không đóng được luôn là học tạo ra một
ngày một cái bảng kia bản phân công cơ
lưu lại quân công giáo viên nào dạy lớp
nào môn nào cơ Thì ra em anh thiếu rồi
đấy
cho nhau mà thôi gửi liền học này nó bạn
chất là nó có phân công rồi nó không sao
giờ
à à
à à Rồi à
ở đây là chắc con sổ 11 và cái nãy lông
để ý nữa đâu Cái này vẫn phải tạo phân
công đúng không Anh nghĩ là giáo viên đã
được được đăng ký theo cái lịch học thì
không cần phân công của anh tức là gió
bộ sẽ tạo ra cái lịch học trước
các bạn sẽ yêu cầu và sẽ cho ta sẽ giống
như là con công với giáo viên nào vậy
cũng đúng đúng chị ăn anh nhậu với em
nhưng mà
à Thế bây giờ bây giờ màu dịch vụ vào
tạo lịch học cho một một lớp vào tuần
sau 3 buổi sáng
246 gạch thì nó sẽ phải đầu tiên nó sẽ
là chọn giáo viên chọn môn chọn lớp
Thuận ca phân tích vào ngày hai thứ Sáu
đúng không à đúng không Đấy sau đó thì
ấn Ok rồi
Có
gì thì
Hi hi không Không ý anh là nó sẽ bị lặp
lại dữ liệu
à vì bản chất là cài à
Ừ để xem
ừ ừ
à Mà thôi sợ không cần Cha à cha cố định
hết rồi nhờ cái tình trạng sinh viên kia
là ở Đức vào trong điểm danh rồi xóa đi
làm chủ nhật là cái này là một dòng tin
nhắn cho em biết đi à
Ừ ok ok sao đùa đấy thì em nổi sinh viên
rồi thằng Điệp thằng lịch học này nn
được nhà ở vì vậy còn mấy cái môn này là
dẫn là một nhiều lúc mà em buồn cái ốp
này vẫn một điều là đúng không ạ
Ừ đúng rồi một giáo viên sẽ có nhiều là
thật nhiều người dậy và một lịch dậy thì
chỉ thủng một giáo viên thôi Đúng giá
cái cái bảng này thì sẽ có mã giáo viên
à không nhập mã môn mã lớp ca mà ngài sẽ
là unique sẽ là ở không bị trùng Bởi vì
trong trong một ca 1 lớp 1 môn thì sẽ
cô gái chỉ cần làm
là phải là lớp ca ngày
đó là đạo unique trong một buổi thì nước
ấy chị học một môn rồi trả
anh không được phép lặp lại được ạ trong
ngày ông đấy
đúng không Bây giờ nếu bạn nhảy thì mình
chỉ còn chưa đến phụ giáo viên chứ không
ạ
hệ thống kê y ý anh ở về sau giả sử giáo
viên có thể dạy hay được nghe đang nói
là khái niệm là để em tránh bị bị sai
thì mà tư liệu ấy là sửa ra
ở nick cả ba rồi đấy sẽ unique đấy
à Còn cái những cái mà nó ra môn học nó
cũng có gì nick gì không Mà
hôm xong cùng làm sao mà học được 2 môn
được à Đúng rồi em Em còn một ca học hay
môn thì em sẽ cho unique cả môn còn
không thì một ca chỉ học một môn thì cần
ba là nếu nick thôi
đúng không ạ
Ừ
ok ta chỉ cần thế thôi có gì nữa
thấy cái cái dịch vụ này có rắn cắn thì
chắc đã hỏi lòng Ok Ok em Thế bây giờ
làm em em cũng chưa hình dung được lắm
cái mồm được vô trong cái bài toán thực
tế thì mày làm thì sẽ hiện lên được thì
cũng đừng ngồi đó
làm không biết à
nhầm tiếp theo nhỉ Còn nhỏ mà nỡ nhỉ
anh ạ
Ừ ok
ừ ừ
vấn chăm sóc sức khỏe
các đối tượng có quản trị viên Bác Sĩ
Nhân viên khách hàng quản trị viên có
quản lý
quản lý giao thông tin của những người
dùng và Lý bác sĩ bác sĩ có nhận vì như
hạnh cập nhật được làm việc cập nhật
trạng thái làm việc nhân viên thì em cho
quản lý liên hệ đặc để sắp xếp để hẹn để
các bác sĩ khách hàng tìm kiếm mà đàn gì
hết á
Ừ bác sĩ
Ai Cập nhật làm việc Nhìn Trong lịch làm
việc thì phân theo cả thì ta đấy thì bác
sĩ không làm được gì
âm nhạc thường nhật mẹ
Ừ thế em thử ví dụ đảm bảo ví dụ là cập
nhật vào lúc nào là sẽ cập nhật như nào
cho ví dụ là cuối tuần là anh cập nhật
cho tuần sau là anh rảnh vào ngày nào á
dành vào buổi nào Hay như nào
Thế thì chiều chắc chắn của chúng ta
được
à à
Ồ thông minh Tĩnh máy tính em Em chưa
cho sửa lỗi cứ chủ nghĩa đã theo em thì
phải là tiện nhất cho người dùng
đúng không mở ca nhưng mà K trong từng
ngày đúng không
Ừ ok rồi Tiếp theo trạng thái làm việc
như này
Ừ Anh nghe tình nhau ca đấy thì tìm bác
sĩ nào bác sĩ nào đến đến làm việc thì
và chưa có cái Đang rảnh mà chưa có cả
bạn là đang thăm ca hoặc là vắng là buồn
Đấy không đến nữa không Không thì cái
đấy nó vẫn còn chung và cái trên đúng
không Xóa sẽ ngon
và lý lịch hệ sắp xếp lịch hẹn để các
bác sĩ không Không cãi sắp xếp lịch hẹn
để các bác sĩ nó hơi bị mối vẫn nhá
Ừ ừ em đặt lịch đặt có thể đặt lịch theo
bác sĩ đâu mà không
có bao nhiêu vậy ạ
AE
AE vẫn có thể sắp xếp lại á anh
ý bác là bác sĩ này đang trong giờ sáng
nhận mà nó có người đặt hiện thì sẽ qua
nhân nhân viên Song tư vấn xong rồi sẽ
sẽ sắp xếp nữa
ở Bình Định Gia Bình Định Nha Trang của
em là cho cái phòng khám của tư nhân
đúng không
và phòng khám đấy có chỉ được phép đặt
trực tiếp chỉ được phép đặt online 2 lần
đặc kiểu đến trực tiếp Hà cũng được
bí mật ong
ý nghĩa là không tạp thì không được đến
khá hay nhỉ
Ừ cái đấy anh chưa Như thế em chỉ đặt
ông
Ừ đúng rồi đạp thì đặt on như nói là đến
thảm trực tiếp được không Nghĩa là không
cần đặt cũng có thể đến khám đúng không
bởi vì nếu mà như bạn có nói
như bạn vừa nói thì nó mới cần phải đặt
sắp xếp lại lịch
a baby Bởi vì nếu không thì không cần
phải sắp xếp lại lịch bởi vì à phần mềm
em phải nó phải hiển thị ra những thời
sự bác sĩ rảnh vào hôm đấy rồi không có
chuyện là có thể đặt được bác sĩ lúc và
bác ái đã được người khác đặc hiệu không
làm việc sắp xếp lại lịch này chỉ phù
hợp khi mà
khách có thể đến đến khám trực tiếp
không còn đặt khi rõ ràng là cái đấy
chưa được lưu vào phần mềm đấy
nữa nếu mà em thích và lưu vào phần mềm
thường là nó vẫn tích và lượng phần mềm
đấy là bác sĩ đang bận rồi không cho đặt
cũng không Không có trường hợp à phải
sắp xếp lại lịch đâu
trừ khi vẫn có cái trường hợp bất đắc dĩ
gì đó bác sĩ hủy lịch vì vấn đề gì đó
lần cả bụng kéo
cho mình già rồi
ừ ok anh ấy hiểu ý tưởng rồi sao chưa
thấy sẽ
ừ ừ
từ ngày
Hamster Apple chính là ca đúng không mở
thì nó ổn hơn
ạ
Vâng trong này thì sẽ cố định hay cao
lại giờ còn này nó hơi bị ạ
em gửi cả chỉ cần lưu lại K là k1 k2 K3
cả
có
Đúng rồi nói không cho rồi đấy Đúng rồi
Nếu mình không có thể lưu lại tận hai
cột như lại một cụ thôi vợ
Are you ready nữa là người dùng đúng
không
tha mai đi hôm nay đi là lịch làm việc
này
Em à em lại tham em đi nổi xa nhà không
thường là nó không đặt treo ca trưởng
ngay đâu nó đặt theo kiểu là từ mấy giờ
mấy giờ đấy
Ừ mình vẫn phải lưu lại thứ mấy giờ mấy
giờ cho nó nhẹ khung giờ của nó là khung
giờ làm việc của bác sĩ thường là đặt
theo cậu là thường anh thấy ở một vài
chỗ thì nó sẽ không phải là hạt là một
ca mà nó càng nhớ theo kiểu là nửa buổi
sáng ngủ buổi chiều nghĩa là tầm 2 tiếng
hai tiếng thứ hai tiếng hai tiếng một
cái
ở
đấy và em khám thì cũng sẽ hai từ hai từ
2 tiếng thì còn được Anh nghĩ cái này nó
phù hợp trong trường hợp này của em đấy
à
à à
anh em yêu em hiểu
ở
link này thì xe máy theo cả tiếp theo
theo treo cặp
Ừ ừ anh anh hiểu Nghĩa là trong cái cái
của em có thể lừa hai tiếng hai tiếng
cũng được không sao không Không cần phải
dùng từ ca thì cũng không đúng lắm nữa
có bề ca ca sáng ca chiều không đúng lắm
đó nó sẽ bị ví dụ từ 8 giờ đến 10 giờ 10
giờ 12:00 kiểu kiểu thế em hiểu vợ ạ
Ba Kể Con tay là gì nhỉ
[âm nhạc]
để khách hàng ghi vào tình trạng bệnh À
thế à mô tả không đúng
chị đánh giá của bác sĩ Ok
ờ ờ Giá
mình sẽ cái giá vào đây
sĩ nữa
anh ạ
[âm nhạc]
có giá giật heo dầu từ bác sĩ đúng không
hiểu từng theo buổi cái gì đó để
mà lúc mà đặt thì mình hiển thị luôn giá
chứ không ngờ
Ê status sau tết ở đây anh sẽ lưu lại
những gì nhỉ
ở trạng thái của các linh kiện này
Ok con ở ở đây xem con gì không nghỉ à
ý nghĩa bản chất Nếu mà liên quan được
cái hủy hay là cái chuyện lịch Vừa nãy
bảo ấy thì nó sẽ bị như thế này đó là
đầu tiên lúc mà đặt người dùng vào trang
của em chọn các bác sĩ đúng không
ở đó thì đặt lịch đúng không sau đó thì
cái trạng thái Cứ cho là một chẳng ạ Tức
là mới đạt đúng không Đây sau đó thì bác
sĩ sẽ vào duyệt cái lịch đấy
Thế
em định cho nhân viên an toàn như thế
liên hệ
nhân viên là không vợ hờ sắp đến bác sĩ
bác sĩ trong nhìn Hẹp ở Nghĩa nhân viên
sẽ liên hệ lại với bác sĩ có thể không
qua phần mềm của em có thể gọi điện ạ
sau đó xác nhận lại là bác sĩ ổn thì sẽ
duyệt lịch đấy chuyện ăn trạng thái hay
ạ thì bệnh thì có thể có thể khám được
đúng không các thứ thứ chứ con à
à Còn nếu mà không thì có thể hủy lịch
thì thức ăn đấy mà hủy lịch thì cũng thì
một là đổi sang trạng thái A3 hay là hai
là đổi bác sĩ đúng không
đã mở
anh vẫn phải lưu lại nhân viên là nhân
viên duyệt nhỉ Hay là nhân viên làm luận
em em chưa Tạo một thực thể nhân nhập
viện em hỏi anh đăng trên có lên quản lý
đi hẹn hò
nó nhận diện được có y tá quản lý thực
hiện Có chứ em Em tạo sau Ok Ok nghĩa
mình phải lưu lại nhân viên nào nhân
viên Diệp cái lịch hẹn đấy nữa Mình sẽ
lưu lại kiểu amin ID ở bạn trong cái
lịch hẹn
hết
nhóm tiếp nhau nhỉ Còn còn nhóm nữa nhỉ
chị đã đủ 20 gì nhỉ Chắc chắn là tôi
thấy còn 15 thì phải đúng không
gì sai sai ở đây
Ừ
tôi diệt tận 27 nhóm mà
Cho mình hỏi ông kia đâu hết rồi Nhóm
kia không trình bày thì
em buổi sau nữa tôi không mất thêm một
buổi Lỡ để ngồi chữa đâu nha mất tận vào
buổi trưa rồi
ở nhà thôi hôm nay có tạm thời đã nếu mà
còn nhó nào ý nhỉ
em buổi sau mình sẽ lại dạy ngùi thường
đi còn nhóm nào muốn chữa nữa thì à
Anh trừ khi là cái đề tài nó khác khác
biệt thì tôi sẽ chữa Còn nếu mà mấy đề
tài trùng với mấy nhóm trước thì chả các
bạn xem tham khảo thôi Tôi tôi nghĩa có
phải nhóm Hôm nay Bị trùng nên thành ra
tham khảo
Thế hả Hôm nay tâm sự à Tôi đang định để
dành thứ bảy được không Gà các bạn không
biết không biết giọng tôi hôm nay mấy
ông có thấy khác không mà hôm nay tôi bị
ốm nhách ốm thì hôm trước thấy thay đổi
được tiết là ốm quá
Ừ thì chắc là để hôm sau Có gì tâm sự
tuổi hồng sau hi vọng hôm sau khỏe hơn
à à Nhân tiện nhắc thành tâm sự thì tôi
có
mày ông lên để thỉnh thoảng xem thôi Có
tổng hợp lại câu họ là tổng hợp tâm sự
với
ông có thể xem trước tôi sẽ chuẩn bị tâm
sự với gì nếu không thích đi tìm hiểu
trước rồi cái để hôm sau còn biết tớ sẽ
chém gió cái gì cái hôm sau tôi sẽ ra
phán vợ mày không nhìn tôi
Khi bữa hôm nay sẽ tặng kết thúc nghỉ
hai tiếng không Xin chào các bạn nha